How long does it take for the right machine to cure it in infection?
Well, the right machine is not always going to cure it in infection, first of all.
Can the right machine really help with the infection, help with the virus, help with the bacteria?
Yes, it can, and we've had cases where it's literally miraculous.
But sometimes you need to take an antibiotic.
Sometimes you need to address the immune system in other ways.
So, highly cautious, caution people to rely on one thing at any given time.
I think the right machine should be at everybody's house.
I think that everybody should have a true right machine.
Not just cancer patients, but I think it could be beneficial for your kids,
if you're unofficial for your families.
I think frequency medicine should be your first thing you go to.
However, it's not a cure-all for everything.
It's not a magic fun, and things do take time.
Even if you are using your properly diagnosed,
and you are using the exact right frequency, it can still take time to heal.
So, that's why having it not going to a practitioner's office, I think, is much better.
Related question, can you use the right machine on your pets?
Yes, you can.
But again, you need proper diagnosis, right?
So, I mean, if you know, if you want your dog to the vet,
the vet says your dog has kidney cancer,
you can definitely run kidney cancer frequencies for your dog.
It might have dramatic effects.
If they say, if you know what's going on with your dog,
or your dog has histamine issues and hives or something,
you could certainly run the histamine programs of your dog.
Again, you really can't hurt yourself,
running the right machine on anything.
The only thing I caution you about is,
running grab negative bacteria programs,
like Borrelia for lying.
Borrelia is a grab negative bacteria,
and it kills the bacteria and can kill it,
and it can kill too quickly.
When you kill a grab negative bacteria too quickly,
you'll generate a lot of liquid polysaccharides,
and you could get a hurt center reaction.
So, that's the only thing I caution you about is,
if it is a grab negative bacteria that you're suspecting,
aka a lie would be the most common.
You gotta go slow, because you don't want to,
you know, and to kill too quickly,
you produce a lot of inner toxins,
and you could feel lucky.